[موسيقى]
مساء الخير عجائب التاريخ والغاز لا تنتهي
والحرب العالميه الاولى واحده من هذه
العجائب والالغاز في مثل هذه الايام من
عام 1914 اندلعت الحرب العالميه الاولى
حرب عجيبه غريبه هناك اجماع انها اذا لم
تكن اهم حدث في القرن العشرين فهي على
الاقل واحده من عدد محدود جدا من الاحداث
التي شكلت تاريخ البشريه
اهميه هذا الحدث لا تحتاجه لجهد كبير
الحرب دي راحه ضحيته اولا ملايين القتلى
والجرحى
وادت لسقوط ثلاث امبراطوريات امبراطوريه
كان اسمها النمسا والمجر الامبراطوريه
العثمانيه الامبراطوريه الروسيه
مهاره الطريق للحرب العالميه الثانيه التي
راح ضحيتها مش ملايين عشرات الملايين من
القتلى ونتائجها هي التي ادت لاندلاع
الحرب البارده نشوء النظام العالمي الذي
نعيش فيه حتى الان
والاهم لنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ان
نتائج هذه الحرب شكلت حدود هذه المنطقه من
العالم من خلال اتفاقات سايكس بيكو
الشهيره ووضعت اول لبنه في بناء الدوله
اليهوديه من خلال وعد بلفور 1917 وكل
الحاجات ديت من توابع ونتائج الحرب
العالميه الاولى
باختصار لا يوجد خلاف على اهميه الحدث
ولكن الغريب ان الخلاف كل الخلاف على
اسبابها حتى يومنا هذا لا احد يعطي اجابه
قاطعه وواضحه على السؤال التالي البسيط
لماذا قامت الحرب العالميه الاولى اصلا
طبعا السبب المباشر للحرب معروف وهو
اغتيال ولي عهد امبراطور النمسا والمجر
وزوجته في مدينه
سراييفو عاصمه البوسنه في 28 يونيو 1914
على يد شاب صربي ولكن هذه الواقعه التي لم
تحظى في الايام الاولى لوقوعها باهتمام
كبير لا تعطي مبررا او تفسيرا وجيها لتورط
قوى كل القوى الكبرى في العالم في حرب
طاحنه لمده اربع سنوات
التفسير الذي بات محل اتفاقنا الان بين
معظم المؤرخين ان عمليه الاغتيال لم تكن
الا عود كبريت عود ثقاب اشعل بيئه كانت
جاهزه للانفجار لاسباب كانت تتشكل خلال
عشرات السنوات التي سبقت الحرب هذه
الاسباب كانت عباره عن حوارث منفصله تسير
في مسارات ساخنه متوازيه تقاطعت كلها في
لحظه عام 1914 مع اغتيال ولي العهد
خلفيه تاريخيه سريعه جدا حتى تستقيم
الامور
اندلعت الثوره الفرنسيه سنه
فزادت اوروبا اشتعالا في هذه الفتره في
هذه السنوات لسبقت الثوره واللي تلتت
الثوره كانت دول وممالك اوروبا في حاله
حرب مستمره فيما بينها لكن الثوره
الفرنسيه اللي حولت فرنسا من مملكه الى
جمهوريه ثوريه زادت القاره اشتعالا خصوصا
بعد صعود نابليون في عام
1799 كقائد فرنسا نابليون غزا معظم دول
اوروبا في الفتره من
1802/18
اللي هي عرفت بحروب نابليون الشهيره
وظلت اوروبا في حاله حرب يعني مستمره الى
ان هزم نابليون في عام 1815 بعد هزيمته
عقدت القوى الاوروبيه سلسله من الاتفاقات
عرفت بمؤتمر فيينا كان هدفها وضع نهائي
لهذه الحروب التي لا تنتهي ونجحوا في ذلك
فعلا وشهدت اوروبا فتره طويله جدا وغير
مسبوقه من الهدوء والسلام سميت باليوروبين
كنسرت او فتره السلام الطويل جدا في
اوروبا استمر من امتى من 1815 الى
1914 لما اندلعت الحرب العالميه الاولى
يعني التسعه وتسعين سنه من الهدوء الهدوء
ده تحقق بفضل مجموعه من العوامل المنطقيه
مش بسبب حسن النوايا السبب الاولاني حاله
اجهاد من الحروب المستمره لقرون النضد
حروب على ايه على الاراضي في اوروبا على
مرض خارج اوروبا النزاعات الملكيه
الخلافات المذهبيه الدينيه الخ ثانيا وهو
الاهم توازن القوى بين الدول الاوروبيه
الكبرى في هذه الفتره توازن القوى يعني
انه ما فيش قوه اقوى بكثير من الاخرين هذا
يعني ادراك هذه القوه الكبرى وقتها ان
تكاليف خوض الحرب سوف تفوق بالتاكيد على
اي فوائد متوقعه قوه كبرى مثل من اللي
كانت موجوده وقتها النمسا بريطانيا فرنسا
روسيا روسيا لكن حدثت متغيرات في منتصف او
بعد منتصف القرن ال19 اول هذه المتغيرات
كان في 1871 اي قبل اندلاع الحرب العالميه
ب 43 سنه عندما توحدت المانيا توحيد
المانيا غير موازين القوه اللي انا كنت
بتكلم عليه اصبحت المانيا المو اقوى دوله
في القاره الاوروبيه
وزادت قوه المانيا لما شكلت تحالف مع
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر المجاوره
واثار صعود المانيا مخاوف القوه الاخرى
وده شيء منطقي فتحالف لمواجهتها روسيا
وفرنسا بدايه من عام
1893 اي ان توحيد المانيا كان سببا رئيسيا
لاشتعال اوروبا مجددا بعد فتره هدوء عمرها
تسعه وتسعين سنه بالاضافه الى حدثين اخرين
اولهما ضم امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر
لمنطقه البوسنه والهرسك ده في سنه 1908 ثم
حروب البلقان اللي جرت بين عامي 1912 و19
تعالوا نلقي الضوء على الحدث الاكبر اللي
ساهم في اشتراع اشتعال الحرب العالميه
الاولى وهو توحيد المانيا لما بنتكلم على
توحيد المانيا في 1871
ازاي تشكلت وهي كانت ايه قبل التوحيد
وازاي توحيدها ساهم في اندلاع الحرب
العالميه الاولى ببساطه قبل سنه 1871 كانت
الشعوب الالمانيه موزعه على كيانات سياسيه
مختلفه كيانات سياسيه يعني اقاليم ومدن
وولايات
وممالك الى اخره 39 كيانا سياسيا كان
اجبرها دوله بروسيا ودوله النمسا خلافتهم
خلافتهم كانت اكثر بكثير من نقاط التفقهم
جمع هذه الكيانات لفتره طويله ما سمي
بالامبراطوريه الرومانيه المقدسه ودي
امبراطوريه ظهرت للوجود تاريخيا بدايه من
سنه 962 واستمرت اكثر من 900 سنه لغايه ما
سقطت في 1806 بعد هزيمتها امام نابليون
بعد هزيمتها رجعت هذه الممالك الالمانيه
او الكائنات الالمانيه مره اخرى يعني في
حاله صراع فيما بينها بشكل كبير جدا
السياسه الالماني الشهير
سمارت نجح في توحيد هذه الكيانات معا
باستثناء
النمسا يعني هم 39 هو وحد 38 كيانا
باستثناء النمسا ولذلك سميت المانيا
الموحده بالمانيا الصغرى يعني كل الكائنات
الالمانيه ماينس النمسا كيف وحدت 38 كيان
بشكل رئيسي باستخدام القوه من خلال ثلاث
حروب اللي هي حروب توحيد المانيا او حروب
بسمارك الشهيره الاولى ضد الدنمارك 1864
الثانيه ضد النمسا 1866 والثالثه ضد فرنسا
بين عامي 1870 و
1871 التوحيد المانيا وهزيمه كل هذه القوى
خصوصا فرنسا ادى لتغيير موازين القوه في
اوروبا عملاق جديد ولد مثال صغير يوضح لك
حجم التغير في موازين القوه مثال اقتصادي
في عام 1870 يعني قبيله توحيد المانيا
بشهور قليله كانت بريطانيا تمتلك 32% من
الطاقه التصنيعيه في العالم
بحلول عام 1910 كانت المانيا بتمتلك حوالي
16% من الطاقه الانتاجيه او التصنيعيه
للعالم بينما بريطانيا بتمتلك اقل من 15
في المئه مع الملاحظه طبعا ان الولايات
المتحده
انتزعت الصداره بفارق كبير جدا حوالي 35%
بس امريكا كانت في عالم اخر وفي قاره اخرى
وبدات المانيا الدوله الصناعيه الكبيره
تبحث عن مستعمرات جديده لتامين احتياجاتها
من المواد الخام واقتدى ذلك
تطوير قدراتها العسكريه وعلى راسها طبعا
الاسطول فشرعت في تطوير اسطول يدارع
الاسطول البريطاني الذي كان الاقوى في
العالم سنه
1897 وداخل البرلمان الالماني عبر وزير
خارجيه المانيا وقتها عن طموحات بلاده
بعباره واضحه جدا ومختصره جدا
كان يرغب في ان نحل محل احد لكننا نرغب في
ان يكون لنا مكان تحت الشمس لكن طبعا
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه والقوه الاوروبيه
الاخرى ما كان لها ابدا ان تشتري هذا
الكلام افتح قوسين كبار
واذكر حضراتكم انه القلق دول الاوروبيه
الكبيره قلقها من المانيا هو مثال كلاسيكي
للمفهوم اللي بلوره البروفيسور جرهام
اليسن الاستاذ في جامعه هارفرد المفهوم ده
اتكلمنا عنه قبل كده وهو اسمه مصيده
ثيوسيدساس او ثيوسيدس تراب
اللي كلمتكم عنه قبل كذا خلاصتها ان
الصراع تاريخيا يقع لمجرد شعور القوى
المهيمنه بالخوف من قوى صاعده حتى وان لم
تسعى لاستفزازها المانيا خايفه من الدول
الاوروبيه والدول الاوروبيه من المانيا
ترتب على خوف الدول من نوايا بعضها البعض
ظهور نظام التحالفات سيء الذكر في نهايه
القرن ال19 وبدايه القرن العشرين خوف
المانيا دفعها للتحالف عسكريا مع
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر في
1879 بعد التلات سنوات انضمت ايطاليا لهم
ليكونوا ما عرف بالتحالف الثلاثي زاد هذا
التحالف من قوه المانيا ولكن في نفس الوقت
زاد من خوف الدول الاخرى من المانيا هذا
دعا فرنسا وروسيا لتشكيل تحالف مضاد في
عام
وانضمت اليهم بريطانيا ودول اخرى لاحقا
هذه قصه المانيا لكن على مسار اخر وفي
سياق مختلف تماما كان للشعب الصربي تاريخ
طويل وغني وتمتعوا بفترات قوه في القرون
الوسطى حتى غزاهم الاتراك او العثمانيون
في عام 14 59
وظلوا تحت الحكم العثماني حتى انتفضوا
عليه في اوائل القرن ال19 وبعد صراع طويل
مع الامبراطوريه التي كانت ضعف قد اصابها
اصبحت صربيا دوله قوميه مستقله ومعترف بها
بدايه من عام 1878
وسرعان ما بدا الصرب يفكرون في حلم بالغ
الخطوره على امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر اي
حلم حلم صربي الكبرى التي تجمع تحت سلطتها
كل الشعوب السلفيه في جنوب اوروبا ومن هم
السلاف هي اكبر جماعه عرقيه في اوروبا زي
ما في منطقه الشرق الاوسط عندنا العرب
والاتراك والتركمان والامازيغ الى اخره
ايضا في اوروبا هناك جماعات عرقيه مختلفه
اكبرها العرق الثلاثي اللي انا هتكلم عنه
بالتفصيل بعد قليل
تحقيق هذا الحلم يقتدي تحرير ملايين
السلاف الذين كانوا يعيشون تحت حكم
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر خصوصا في منطقه
البلقان لو مش عارفين ايه هي منطقه
البلقان ببساطه هي المنطقه اللي موجوده في
جنوب اوروبا شمال البحر المتوسط واللي
بتوجد فيها الان دول البانيا وكسوفه
وبلغاريا والبوسنه والهرسك والجبل الاسود
وكرواتيا ومقدونيا واليونان وجزء من تركيا
وطبعا صربيا الخريطه ممكن توضح ده بسهوله
في هذا الاطار في سنه 1908 ومع ضعف
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه ضمت رسميا
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر منطقه البوسنه
والهرسك والتي كانت مستعمره عثمانيه لماذا
سعه النمسا والمجر لضم البوسنه الاجابه
لتطويق صربيا صربيا كانت ذاخره بقوه قوميه
ترغب في توحيد الشعوب الثلاثيه في جنوب
اوروبا زي ما قلت لحضراتكم وهذا خطر على
الامبراطوريه التي كانت تضم عرقيات كثيره
جدا
وطموح الصرب سيؤدي لفوضى لن تقتصر على
انفصال السلاف ولكنها ستنتقل سوف تنقل
العدوى يعني لكل العرقيات الاخرى وتتفكك
الامبراطوريه الكبيره ادراكا من
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر لطموحات صربيا
الخطيره عليها ارادت تطويقها باحتلال
منطقه البوسنه والهرسك والمنطقه وهذا الضم
اثار غضب صربيا بشده لعده اسباب اولا ضم
البوسنه كان واحدا من عده تحركات
للامبراطوريه في منطقه البلقان هدفوها
الابقاء على صربيا دوله حبيسه محرومه من
اطلاله على البحر ثم انها كانت على الارجح
تفضل ضم البوسنه لها كجزء من تحقيق حلمها
الكبير في الصرب الكبرى وطبعا الضم سوف
يزيد من قوه
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر المعاديه لها
حشدت صربيا جيشها ردا على عمليه الضم في
1908 لكنها تراجعت لاحقا بعد فشلها في
تامين دعم الشقيق الكبرى روسيا بعدها
بسنوات قليله اندلعت حرب البلقان 1912
1913 اعمل بحث صغير كده على حروب البلقان
هتاخد فكره اكتر لكن خلاصتها او خلاصه اهم
نتائج هذه الحرب ان الصربيه خرجت اكثر قوه
مما كانت لانها انتصرت على اولا
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه اللي كانت بدات
تضعف بشده ثم على حليفتها حليفه صربيا
السابقه اللي هي بلغاريا وانتصار صربي على
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه وعلى بلغاريا ضاعف
من حجم صربيا وزاد من عدد سكانها ما اثار
قلق امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر خصوصا مع
ازدهار الجامعات القوميه الثلاثيه داخل
صربيا الجامعات دي كانت باختصار لها هد
اساسيين هدف انا اشرت اليه وهي حمايه حقوق
الشعاب الشعوب الثلاثيه في المنطقه وعلى
المدى الطويل اخراج النمسا والمجر من
منطقه البلقان كلها
ملحوظتين مهمتين جدا توضحوا لك قد ايه
المساله دي كانت خطيره على امبراطوريه
النمسا والمجر اللي كانت واحده من القوى
الكبرى في ذلك الوقت الملحوظه الاولى انه
النمسا والمجر لم تكن مثل القوى الكبرى
الاخرى المتجانسه الى حد كبير المانيا
مثلا كانت بشكل رئيسي موطنا للالمان اما
امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر فقد ضمت رسميا
وضعت تحت كلمه رسميا خط لانه عدد العرقيات
اللي كان غير رسمي كان اكثر عراقيات اكثر
ولكن كانت قليله العدد رسميا كان في 11
عرقيه مختلفه بتكون هذه الامبراطوريه
عرقيه زي ايه المان
بولنديين ايطاليين وصربي طبعا ما يعني ان
انفصال اي عرقيه يمكن ان يؤدي لعدوى
الانفصال بين باقي العرق بين باقي
العرقيات وتنهار الامبراطوريه ثانيا حتى
لو اقتصرت الميول الانفصاليه على الشعوب
الثلاثيه وحدها ولم تنتقل العدوى للقوميات
الاخرى فالمشكله كبيره جدا السلاف هم اكبر
عرقيه في اوروبا زي ما قلت لكم وموزعين
بالمناسبه على الثلاث مناطق رئيسيه كانوا
وما زالوا موزعين على التلات مناطق رئيسيه
السلاف الشرقيين ودول بيشملوا الثلاث دول
الموجودين الان بيلاروس وروسيا واوكرانيا
افتح قسم كبار علشان كده دايما بوتين
بيقول نحن واوكرانيا شعب واحد عندنا اصل
واحد بيقول له ايوه احنا فعلا اخوات لكن
انت بتمثل قابيل الذي قتل هابيل ودي قصه
شرحها والسلافه الغربيين ودول موجودين في
جمهوريه التشيك وبولندا وسلوفاكيا
والسولاف الجنوبيين وهم الذي يعيشون في
البوسنه والهرسك وبالغريه وكرواتيا
ومقدونيا والجبل الاسود والصربيا اي
مكونات منطقه البلقان الان
والمكونات اللي شكلت بعد كده دوله
يوغسلافيا بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى
واللي يعني ظلت دوله
الى ان انهارت في التسعينات في خلال حروب
يوغوسلافيا والمناسبه كلمه يوغوسلافيا
يعني موطن اليوغوسلاف الجنوبيين على كل
الاحوال
باختصار دعوه صربيه لتكون وطنا قوميا لكل
السلاف الجنوبيين
كانت تعني للامبراطوريه امبراطوريه النمسا
والمجر خطرا شديدا على مستويين الاول خروج
الشعوب الثلاثيه من تحت عباءتها وانضمامهم
لدوله جديده معاديه اللي هي صربيا الامر
الثاني ان هذه الدوله اللي هي صربيا بحكم
التركيب العرقيه هي حليف لدوله اخرى كبيره
معاديه لها وهي روسيا لكل هذه الاسباب
كانت النمسا والمجر تنتظر اي فرصه للتقضي
على صربيا وفي هذه الاثناء نجع شاب صربي
فاغتيال ولي العهد النمساوي اثناء زيارته
لصراييف عاصمه البوسنه اللي كانوا ضموها
سنه
1908 زي ما قلت لحضراتكم وهذا الاغتيال تم
في 28 يونيو 1914 الشاب اللي كان عمره 19
سنه فقط لا غير واسمه
كان ينتمي لجماعه قوميه عرفت اليد السوداء
وما هي اليد السوداء واحد من التنظيمات
القوميه الكثيره اللي كانت موجوده في
صربيا والمستعده لممارسه العنف لتحقيق
الهدفين للجماعات الثلاثيه القوميه دوله
قوميه واحده للشعوب السلفيه وطرد النمسا
والمجر من البلقان افتح قوسين من عجائب
القدر انه جامعه اليد السوداء ارسلت فريق
من عدد من الشباب
لمحاوله اغتيال ولي العهد
وحاولوا يلقوا القوا عليه بالفعل قنبله في
صباح هذا اليوم 28 يونيو ولكنه نجا واصيب
احد ضباط المرافقه ولي العهد اللي نجا من
محاوله الاغتيال اراد زياره هذا الضابط
وفقا لاحدى الروايات السائق اللي كان
بيزوق بيقود الكارج بتاعته ضلت طريق بطريق
المصادفه وهذا
يعني هذا الخاطئ اللي بيسموه في التاريخ
الرونج تيرن
وضعوا بشكل عجيب غريب في مواجهه قاتله
اللي هو
اللي كان تخلى خلاص عن مخططاته في هذا
اليوم الاغتيال ولي العهد بعد فشل محاوله
الصباح وجد نفسه على غير تدبير امام موكب
ولي العهد وكان في حوزته مسدس فاطلق عليه
الرصاص اللي ارداه وارضى زوجته قتيلا
سبحان الله نفر من قضاء الله الى قضاء
الله وكان هذه المصادفه العجيبه الغريبه
هي التي ادت الى اشعال الحرب العالميه
الاولى على كل الاحوال بلغ اغتيال ولي
العهد في 28 يونيو اتخاذ القوى الاوروبيه
مجموعه من القرارات المتواليه التي ثبت
انها بنيت على حساب حسابات خاطئه ادت في
نهايه المطاف لاندلاع حرب الكبرى لم
يتوقعها ولم يتمناها اي من اطرافها كيف
ذلك اعتقد
فضلا بقى عن رغبتها في البحث عن رغبتها في
البحث عن ذريعه لصحق الصرب والقضاء على
تهديداتهم المستمره منذ سنوات كما اشرت
لحضراتكم
ارسلت صربيا ارسلت اسف امبراطوريه النمسا
والمجر انذارها الشهير في 23 يوليو والذي
تضمن شروطا مذله لصربيا واضطرت الحكومه
الصربيه اللي كانت غير راغبه لقتال هذه
الامبراطوريه الكبيره لقبول كل الشروط ما
عدا شرطا واحدا وهو قيام الامبراطوريه
الاله امبراطوريه النمسا والمجر يعني
بتحقيق مستقل في الحارث اعتبر ده عدوان
على سيادتها يصعب جدا ان تقبله فاعلنت
النمسا والمجرى الحرب على صربيا في 28
يوليو
1914 يعني بعد حوالي شهر من حادث الاغتيال
اقل من شهر لكنها لم تعلن الحرب الا بعد
ان تشاورت مع حليفتها الرئيسيه والوحيده
المانيا
حسابات النمسا كانت كالاتي القضاء على
صربيا ليس مشكله لكن المشكله في روسيا
التي من المتوقع ان تهب لنجدتها ولماذا
تهب روسيا لنجده صربيا
اولا لانها رات وما زالت ترى نفسها على
هذا النحو يعني حاميه للشعوب السلفيه واذا
سكتت واثارت السلامه فلن
تفقد فقط حليفا لها وهي صربيا ولكنها
ستفقد هيبتها خصوصا بعد هزيمتها المحرجه
امام اليابان في 1905
وهذه الفكره عبر عنها بوضوح وزير الخارجيه
الروسي وقتها
دخوله روسيا الحرب دفاعا عن صربيا
الثلاثيه على النحو التالي اذا فشلت روسيا
في اداء مهمتها التاريخيه اليوم
فسوف تعد سوف تعتبر دوله ضعيفه
وستحتل من من الان فصاعدا مرتبه ادنى
مرتبه ثانيه بين القوى الكبرى طمانه
المانيا النمسا انا قلت لكم انها راحت
تستشير المانيا طمنت المانيا النمسا
والمجر واعطتها بالفعل في 5 يوليو 1914
وعدا بدعم مطلق في حربها على صربيا في
حربها على صربيا اسمه المؤرخون ذا بلانك
تشك او شيكا على بياض
كثيره واللي ترددت ورفضت انها تهرع لنجده
صربيا اللي ارادت حرب النمسا والمجر في
1908 لن تغامر بحرب كبرى من اجل صربيا
ايضا
الروس خافوا خافوا لما شافوا انه النمسا
والمجر بتعلن الحرب على صربيا وخافوا لانه
المانيا دعمت النمسا والمجر خوف الروس
جعلهم يبداوا في تعبئه قواتهم بدايه من 30
يوليو كاجراء احترازي في حاله اندلاع
الحرب
لما الالمان شافوا الروس بيعملوا عمليه
تعبئه خافوا وراوا في هذه التعبئه عملا
عدوانيا بيستهدفهم ويستهدف النمسا والمجر
ليه فكروا بالشكل ده ده وضع طبيعي دوله
كبيره معاديه بتعبئ قوتها على الحدود معها
اكيد دول مش رايحين حفله شاي
وكان على الالمان ان يتحركوا عسكريا باسرع
وقت ممكن وضع تحت اسرع وقت ممكن ديت عده
خطوط ولازم نسال ليه باسرع وقت ممكن
ببساطه المانيا كانت جاهزه بخطه عسكريه
لسيناريو الحرب ضد الدولتين اللي تحالفوا
عسكريا ضدها من سنوات عديده هذه الخطه
عرفت باسم خطه شليف في التاريخ الخطه طبعا
اسمها شليفن على اسم الجنرال فانوس ليفن
اللي شغل منصب رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
في الامبراطوريه الالمانيه من عام 1891 ل
06 الخطه بتاعته اللي ادخل عليها تعديلات
افترضت انه المانيا سوف تواجه حربا على
جبهتين مين الجبهتين فرنسا وروسيا اللي
تحالفوا ضد الامبراطوريه الالمانيه زي ما
وضحت لحضراتكم
وكان تصورها كالاتي ان روسيا بعد ان خسرت
حربها امام اليابان في 1905 هتحتاج ما لا
يقل ابدا عن سته اسابيع على الاقل لتعبئه
قواتها بشكل يمكنها من مهاجمه المانيا من
الشرق في ذلك الوقت على المانيا ان تستفيد
من عنصر الوقت وتهاجم فرنسا الاضعف عسكريا
بالسير غربا عبر الاراضي المحايده لبلجيكا
طب وليه اروح لبلجيكا علشان اتجنب الحدود
المباشره شريده التحصين مع فرنسا
وتوقعت النجاح في حصار وسحق القوات
الفرنسيه وبمجرد هزيمه فرنسا ووفقا للخطه
يمكن لالمانيا نقل جنودها شرقا باستخدام
شبكه السكك الحديديه الخاصه بها ونشرها ضد
القوات الروسيه والتي اعتقد
والجنرالات الذين ادخلوا تعديلات على
خطتها على خطته انها لن تكون قد استكملت
تعبئه جنودها بالكامل وبالتالي يسهل
هزيمتها عنصر الوقت اللي كان محسوب
بالساعات وبالايام كان بالغ الحساسيه في
خطه المانيا وعليها ان تبادل الان وقد
بادرت بالفعل يعني وجود الخطه ده خلى
الالمان ما يدوش فرصه للمفاوضات وسلسله من
القرارات والقراءه الخاطئه لنوايا الاخرين
كله خايف من ان يؤكل فيريد ان يبادر بان
ياكل الطرف الاخر او يبادر بالعدوان على
الطرف الاخر في 31 يوليو ارسلت المانيا
انذارا نهائيا الى روسيا تطالبها بتسريح
قواتها في اليوم التالي انتهى الانذار دون
رد فاعلنت المانيا الحرب على روسيا وامرت
بتعبئه بتعبئه جنودها وكان من الطبيعه ان
تهب فرنسا لدعم حليفتها روسيا ضد عدوته
المانيا فرنسيين كانوا بيامروا في
الانتقام لهزيمتهم في حرب 1870 ضد بروسيا
اللي اصبحت بعد كده المانيا واعلنت
المانيا بدورها الحرب على فرنسا في ثلاثه
اغسطس
فين بريطانيا من كل ده في البدايه
بريطانيا كانت بعيده عن الازمه الى حد
كبير واعتبرت ان اغتيال ولي عهد النمسا
والبقا المجر ازمه يعني بعيده عنها خصوصا
وانها كانت منشغله بقضايا داخليه ومحليه
متعدده اهمها خطر الحرب الاهليه في
ايرلندا والاندلعت بالفعل لكن بدايه من
اخر يوليو وتحديدا في 24 يوليو ساعه لان
تقوم بدور الوسيط املا في الا تقوم هذه
الحرب حاول وزير الخارجيه البريطاني تنظيم
مؤتمر سلام دولي لمنع المزيد من التصعيد
قابلت فرنسا مقترحاته ورفضتها المانيا
واعتبرها غير منصفه للالمان او غير مطمئنه
للالمان في 29 يوليو طلب الحياد البريطاني
في حال نشوب حرب اوروبيه وهو ما رفضته
بريطانيا طبعا لان حسابات بريطانيه اذا
الحرب قامت لازم اكون مع فرنسا
ببساطه لان انتصار الماني وهو اللي كان
متوقع ان هي لم تدخل الى الحرب سوف يمنح
المانيا نفوضا ضخما جدا على اوروبا
الغربيه من شانه ان يرسخ سيطرتها على دول
اوروبا وعلى ساحل القناه الانجليزي ويشكل
تهديدا لبريطانيا العظمى وعلى مصالحها
وعلى تجارتها وبدات بريطانيا تستعد بالفعل
لحرب المحتمله في واحد اغسطس حشد
البريطانيون قوتهم البحريه ووعدوا
الفرنسيين بحمايه الساحل الفرنسي من
العدوان الالماني والاكثر من كده ان في
اثنين اغسطس حدث ما هو اهم اذ وافق مجلس
الوزراء البريطاني على دعم بلجيكا اذا
تعرضت للهجوم ليبلجيكا لتلات اسباب واحد
بلجيكا كانت رسميا دوله محايده وفقا
لمعاهده وقعتها القوى الاوروبيه الكبرى في
عام 1839 ثانيا موقعها خطير جدا على كل
القوى الكبرى وخصوصا بريطانيا
نظره واحده للخريطه توضح ذلك سيطره
المانيا عليها تمنحها ببساطه سيطره على
شواطئ القناه الانجليزيه وتهدد بريطانيا
ثالثا ان بريطانيا مدركه تماما انه موقع
بلجيكا يجعلها اختيار منطقي للهجوم
الالماني على فرنسا بعد اعلان الحرب على
فرنسا من جانب المانيا طبعا بدا الالمان
في تنفيذ خطته
تنفيذ الخطه كان يقتدي ايه انه يبدا
بمهاجمه فرنسا اولا ثم يذهب بعد هزيبتها
الى روسيا وتطلبت الخطه زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم ان القوات الالمانيه تغزو بلجيكا
للوصول الى فرنسا او للادق ان تمر عبر
بلجيكا ما كانش في نيتها غزو بلجيكا
في يوم اتنين اغسطس 1914 طلبت المانيا من
حكومه بلجيكا
للسماح بقواتها للسماح لقواتها بالمرور
عبر اراضيها بديهي رفضت بلجيكا لان هذا
يعني مشاركه للالمان في حربهم على فرنسا
فقرر الالمان دخول الاراضي البلجيكيه
بالقوه غزوها الساعه اتنين
ظهر يوم 4 اغسطس اصدرت المملكه البريطانيه
انذارا نهائيا لالمانيا بسحب قواتها من
بلجيكا لم يستجب الالمان فاعلنت بريطانيا
الحرب عليها واندلعت الحرب وعلى عكس ما
توقع
استمرت الحرب اربع سنوات وليست بضعه
اسابيع اقتصرت في بدايتها اي بدايه من
اغسطس 1914 على طرفيها الرئيسيين بريطانيا
وفرنسا وروسيا ما سمي بالوفاق الثلاثي او
الحلفاء ضد دولتي النمسا والمجر والمانيا
او القوه المركزيه ثم اتسع نطاق الحرب
وتعدلت اطرافها فاعلنت ايطاليا الحرب على
دول القوى المركزيه في مايو 1915 افتح
قوسين موقف ايطاليا كان مربك تحالفت مع
المانيا والنمسا والمجر ثم اعلنت الحياه
ثم انضمت الى قوى الحلفاء طمعا في ان هي
تحصل على اراضي بعد هزيمه امبراطوريه
النمسا والمجر على العموم ثم انضمت
الولايات المتحده واليابان ودول اخرى الى
قوى الحلفاء لاحقا
وانضمت الامبراطوريه العثمانيه وبلغاريا
الى القوى المركزيه وانسحبت روسيا بالكامل
من الحرب بعد اندلاع الثوره البلشفيه 1917
مات ملايين الجنود والمدنيين اختفت حكومات
وانظمه انهارت ثلاث امبراطوريات رسمت حدود
دول جديده ومنها دول الشرق الاوسط نتيجه
سقوط الامبراطوريه العثمانيه وسيطره
الحلفاء على مستعمراتها وبالتالي تقسيم
المنطقه وفقا لاتفاقات فرنسا وبريطانيا
بشكل رئيسي تفقات سايكس بيكو وفي الشرق
الاوسط زرعت بذره اسرائيل التي سوف تغير
تاريخ المنطقه من خلال وعد بلفور ببساطه
وعد بلفور كان هدفه الرئيسي اغراء اليهود
المؤثرين خصوصا في امريكا للضغط على
حكومتهم بالدخول للحرب الى جانب الحلفاء
وكتبت نهايه الحرب حرب العالميه الاولى
اللي كانت بتسمى بالحرب العظمى وبعد كده
سميت الحرب العالميه الاولى في وقت لاحق
تمييز الله عن الحرب العالميه الثانيه
شهاده ميلاد الحرب العالميه الثانيه ليه
لانه الحرب انتهت ان الجانب المنتصر اللي
هي قواته الحلفاء وضعوا شروط المذله
للالمان مهاره الطريق لصعود هتلر وشعور
الطليان انهم شاركوا مع الحلفاء في الحرب
لكنهم حصلوا على فتات
جعل الطليان يشعروا بالغصه
والاهانه ما مهد الطريق لظهور موسوليني
ظهور هتلر في المانيا ظهور موسوليني في
ايطاليا معهد الطريق للحرب العالميه
الثانيه ثم الحرب البارده ثم النظام
العالمي الذي يحكمنا والذي افرز تاسيس حلف
شمال الاطلسي الذي سعوا النيتو يعني الذي
سعى مره اخرى للتوسع على حساب قوى مهزومه
في هذه الحاله اتحاد السوفيتي وخليفته
روسيا التي شعرت بالاظلال مباحث لظهور
بوتين الذي بدا في حروب منذ عام 2008
اخرها اوكرانيا ولا والتي قد تضع العالم
على طريق حرب عالميه جديده الحرب العالميه
الاولى حملت دروس حفظها ساسه الدول الكبرى
لسنوات طويله وحفظهم لهذه الدروس جنبنا
حروبا كثيره منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لكن كثير من هذه الدروس بدا
يتلاشى والنتيجه اننا على ابواب حرب
عالميه جديده لاننا تجاهلنا دروس الحرب
العظمى ومنها خطا الاندفاع لحرب دون
استنفاذ كل فرص التفاوض هذا ما حدث في
الحرب العالميه الاولى لماذا
ببساطه بسبب قناعه الكثير من قاده بعض
الدول اما الحرب ستكون خاطفه محدوده
وستحقق نتائج سريعه هذه كانت حسابات بوتين
بالمناسبه
في حربه الاخيره على اوكرانيا تماما مثل
حسابات قاده الدول الذين تورطوا في الحرب
العالميه الاولى من اكثر من 100 سنه
اعتقادهم انها سوف تكون حربا سريعه الدرس
الثاني ما ان يتخذ قائد اي دوله قرار
الحرب يصعب عليه ان يتحكم في مسارها وهذا
هو الحادث الان الكل عاجز عن انهاء الحرب
في اوكرانيا لانه انهاء الحرب ليس ميسورا
مثل قرار الاتخاذ القرار ببدئها الدرس
الثالث ان السلام السيء يمهد لحروب جديده
بالضروره انتهت الحرب العالميه الاولى
باتفاق سلام مذل للالمان ممهد الطريق
لصعود هتلر الراغب في الانتقام بدعم شعبي
كبير من الالمان ايضا الان دول الغرب نست
هذا الدرس وارادت اذلال الروس بتوسيع حلف
شمال الاطلسي شرقا النتيجه حروب من 2008
زي ما قلت لحضراتكم كان اخرها حرب
اوكرانيا حتى نظام الاحلاف سيء السمعه في
بدايه القرن العشرين الذي جرى كل دول
اوروبا للحرب يعود الان بشكل واضح في سوره
النيتو الذي تم مؤخرا فنلندا والسويد بعد
ان تخلاه عن حيادهما وبعد بضم اوكرانيا في
اجتماعهم الاخير منذ ايام
باختصار العالم بيعيش مجددا في صيف 1914
نامل ان لا يكرر قاده العالم ما فعلوه منذ
اكثر من مئه عام اشكركم والى لقاء